You look fantastic.
Thank you.
You look like
you take very good care of yourself.
Thank you so much for noticing.
No, I mean that.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
But you also look like,
I have people on the show that look like,
and they tell me, oh I love working out.
They love doing it.
You strike me, your personality is
you're not a person that wants to work out.
No, and I'm not.
Thank you so much for saying so.
(audience laughs)
Thank you for noticing
that my physique is like a person who exercises
and my personality is not.
That is a typology that I strive to really transmit.
(Conan laughs)
Thank you so much.
Kate Mulgrew who plays Red on Orange, she always says,
"I don't believe you work out," in character she says to me.
And I think that's
because I exercise exclusively in the dark.
I try to not be found exercising.
I'll walk into a gym class.
I like gym classes that are very dark
and I put in ear plugs, I go to the back corner,
I found the whole thing highly humiliating.
Modern people, what do they like?
They like putting on Katy Perry or something, high-fiving.
I don't like that kind of a thing.
I find that very minimi lazing as a human being.
I don't wanna high-five you.
(audience laughs)
If, let's say, you're the gym instructor which I think of,
then if you come up to me in the middle of the class
and my eyes are closed, I'm just trying to make it through,
just survive by the skin of my teeth.
Then you suddenly high-five me, I'm terrified.
I find that terrifying.
Are you talking about a spin class.
Is that what you're talking about?
Vaguely but I was trying to be non-specific on purpose,
ya know, for shame.
Okay.
Because I went to a spin class once and I love to ride.
I ride a bike like out in the world.
But I went to a spin class.
My wife loves spin class and she's like, you gotta try it.
I went there and there was too much enthusiasm in the room.
That's what was getting me.
That's what I don't like!
And the woman at the front was going like,
"Come on, everybody, oh oh!"
And everyone was like, "Oh, oh!"
I hate that!
And like,
"Come on everybody!"
Where do you want me to go, I'm on the bicycle.
Know what I mean?
Yeah.
And why is it even orchestrated this way?
Incidentally I saw a great video of you guys
over the weekend at a party involving wrestling
which I just wanna let you know.
You were dressed like a sort of a turkey or something.
What are you talking about?
Oh, oh, yeah.
From the Mexico show.
Oh!
From Mexico.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what it was.
I thought you had a stroke.
Yes, yes, yes, also I had a stroke.
But I'm back, baby!
Andy and I when we did our Mexico show,
we did Mexican wrestling and we dressed up.
We were Luchadores.
Now I do have another, I just think of it
because we're exercising and you guys were in leotards.
I do have a wonderful trainer, Joe Holder,
but he also trains proper super models
like Naomi Campbell and stuff.
I'm always wondering when is the part
where I get to be like Naomi Campbell which is why
I think the amount of complaining is turning into
a sort of Larry David of the gym.
That's why I feel like I don't go.
I don't wanna be jumping, I don't wanna work too hard.
I feel like there's people there, the lights are on.
Naomi is always on his Instagram.
I feel like I'm never featured.
(Andy and audience laugh)
I'm wondering what I'm not doing that's not accomplishing--
What are you wearing when you work out?
Do you wear the cool workout clothes?
There's a whole look.
A blazer, a blazer.
A blazer.
(Andy and audience laugh)
A blazer, a T-shirt that says Gold Gym.
Ya know, bell bottoms and Gucci loafers.
And let me guess, you're smoking the whole time.
And I'm smoking and I'm like,
hey you do the push-ups baby.
(all laugh)
That's how I exercise.
I love it, that's the way to do it.
(audience woots and claps)